[Music]
welcome back to careful boys
uh one of my favorite ways that ryan
likes to open the show is he goes
welcome back to careful boys well we are
currently
off the record oh it's like it's like
we're on a [ __ ] 60 minutes
i like that pause dude i like i like to
make it a little naughty it's just
dramatic no i ain't no not a boy
and you don't even talk like that ever
but for some reason when you do that
intro he's like but we are currently off
the record oh he goes like this you
should start doing this yeah very cool
yeah when the cameras are off he's just
an italian voice i do feel more uh
comfortable when you say that though
really yeah because i'm off director i
say what the [ __ ] i want yeah
that's why because we are bombs on it
and this is going on youtube but you
know what though off the record like
pre-2019
was much different because we weren't
scared of [ __ ] like getting canceled
and we weren't scared of like youtube
taking us off but hey at least now we're
really nice and fearful
that's why we're the careful boys hey
right now dude we just got to get fear
everyone tattoos
are you guys down do you guys want to
get money like that dude i will actually
get one get mine in english everyone
all right how about this if we survive
one more year should we all get fear
everyone tattoos absolutely it sounds
like the worst idea we've ever are we
down i'm in if we survive one more year
starting when today like like we like
2023 you know what i'm so confident we
won't survive another unit
[Laughter]
august
2023 we're all gonna get [ __ ]
matching tattoos especially if you guys
are still here oh [ __ ] it seems even
less likely yeah no matter what me and
far we're we're gonna [ __ ] end to the
end the funny thing is there's gonna be
another member that you guys never met
with the same matching tattoo i can't
wait and i know who this guy is i
haven't talked to him in ages that's
right because it's sports party yeah
yeah yeah all right maybe we could do
like a like a reunion video or something
with them with our tattoos honestly i've
been thinking about that yeah i was
thinking about like all the people that
like uh either we had beef or whatever
with or passed with
it'd be cool to do like some sort of
mini documentary on jk news where people
like like they walk you know from
opposite sides of like the [ __ ]
street and they meet and see if they hug
or [ __ ] kiss or whatever if they hug
to experiment that is the most soft
thing you've said in a long time yeah i
love softy i want to be there for like
the before we start shooting that like
how weird that is yeah yeah yeah
i want to be there for pre-production
yeah like what the [ __ ] you have to get
them on the both sides of the street hey
just wait for it's like we got to wait
hold on we got lighting i want to get a
b camera that's hiding behind the bushes
trying to get all the candid stuff
camera blocking for that that's like
when you're watching i would love to get
yeah xjk members or anybody just have
them get out of their car and like
walking around while we do a voiceover
like [ __ ] 2020 and [ __ ]
yeah that'll be so funny speaking of the
office i guess that's kind of where this
is leaning anyway yeah what a [ __ ]
mess right yeah no um
what about so why do you think we might
not survive another year
candid talk to be completely honest with
you guys full disclosure okay we are off
the record
okay so be real dude all right so um
um
the recession
hardcore like uh we actually started jk
during the first recession 2007. well
that was right before right
and then at that time youtube wasn't
monetizing and and the any money we were
getting were like college students we
didn't have a company right
but just recently um me and a bunch of
other friends and many companies
uh
they lost a lot of their sponsorships
we lost about
over 50
of just
income from sponsors so when you watch
the off the records you're gonna
probably not see us
tell you that you know this video is
brought to you by fields
yes yeah
no but it hurts us
it's good for you guys
in the middle yeah that was the only way
we were able to kind of keep going um
you know because uh once we were
suspended on youtube what ended up
happening was uh we couldn't post for
like a month so we're like [ __ ] what are
we gonna do thankfully we had the
support of our fans that wanted us to
keep going so we're like you know what
we'll just go on patreon
and patreon to me was just like a
bandage because ultimately if you don't
stay on youtube you don't get access to
the eyes that see you every day so you
only have like a select few of people
and we had like what about 5 000 people
that were solidly supporting us
but eventually you know if people are
used to going on youtube every day
they're not going to open another app
just for one creator or maybe like
they're supporting two but life always
happens and even me like you know i'm
subscribed to things but
every six months i'll probably cancel
all of them and then eventually it'll
start dwindling especially if you don't
show premium content once we got back on
youtube um
there was no real point to go on patreon
unless you wanted to see the most
exclusive [ __ ] that we're afraid of
being canceled for on youtube so on
patreon you're gonna get like all the
more 2018
previous jk vibes right whereas now we
have to be the careful boys on youtube
and so all these different things kind
of shifted
and um so with the combination of
adsense going down plus the sponsorships
going down so it's like okay it might be
a point in jk where me and bart might
have to just funnel money from other
things to keep this thing going yeah
damn that's super dark yeah
total [ __ ] bummer
and that's why i was like yo man did we
will we survive another year i mean [ __ ]
i don't know dude at the end of the day
the way i see this place is like hey if
other things pop off for me like i'm
putting money back in here so we can
keep going because
this is great like i don't know i don't
know like there's nothing to complain
about like this is we're getting paid to
get up like meet up and like talk and
hang out
and it's like how many times a month do
we
do this
i don't know we just need all jumpsuits
that's what it really is trying to get
that going but um so far it's a lonely
operation steve has to finance jk
because he's the only baller here he
finances his own uh wardrobe
and on top of that his own trip to jk
pretty much he loses money to come here
i do it's fun i like it i like looking
at the balance sheet i like looking at
the budget i like all of it i like being
the negative oh no honestly i really do
like i love coming here always have um
so yeah even though yeah i do pay a lot
of money to come here i pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars to come here
[Laughter]
who told you to fly private though all
right dude i'm telling you i only saved
the best hotels
[Laughter]
no it's been interesting it's been hella
interesting just because um
yeah like post you know [ __ ]
careful boys it's been really fun like
very very very fun this new group i
[ __ ] i'm loving it dude so i like to
i would like to keep doing whatever this
is exactly
for as long as we can yeah yeah so yeah
you know
i feel like we're
just getting on a roll too you know what
i mean um we're gonna start really just
having fun you know even get into a
space where even off camera we're
looking at each other we're like hey man
forget some of the guests sometimes man
let's just like let this vibe you know
be what it is especially for guys like
me and nick and ryan who you know just
became regulars in the last like year
and stuff you know to constantly well i
thought you're on the show forever
though
before you yeah
but uh you haven't put too much time so
that's not no
but yeah you know it's just like finally
catching the flow and and getting into
like a momentum that is not just like
dope i think i really do think the
content is [ __ ] sick as [ __ ] because
it's hilarious but also just the vibes
right it's always just dope coming in
every day the nuances the the attitude
the energy whether it's you getting
crazy off of a [ __ ] cafe whether it's
like ryan always bringing in donuts you
know whether steve's always showing up
late so we always never come home on
time or like messes up our relationships
at home and stuff like that
and nick's finally just started to open
up right after like six thousand videos
that's it no i'm done cut you guys off
ever so the idea is that that we're like
just getting to that place where i'm
like i feel like the momentum and the
chemistry is like [ __ ] sick
um yet to have such
macro socio-economic things that are
making a little bit more tough is is
to be humbled you know what i mean it's
it's challenging it [ __ ] sucks yeah
it's dark to think about you know when
we got earlier this year when the when
we got together and then like created
this careful boys crew right
we were actually going back on track we
were getting more sponsorships
everything was like on the up and up and
then it's like we got rug pulled by the
sponsors hey we got rug pull multiple
times bro let's be honest
that's christ
you got rugby
we got rug pulled that's kind of where
we
um
the way i feel about it is like i love
this group and it's [ __ ] fun
and i do feel like we definitely hit a
stride and you know like anthony was
saying like there's times where like
you know we're excited to see the guest
and the guest comes in and i'm like
damn it was kind of funny without the
guests
like who specifically yeah what name
name them top three oh like davis so
yeah like davidson
especially david's this comes in ruins
the vibe yeah yeah it makes fun of all
of us he just bullies everybody so it
does kind of suck to like have uh
factors beyond your control like the
recession and like the ads pulling out
or even adsense paying less and [ __ ]
like that
so i think that's the part where it's
like i think me and joe have to go back
and like be actual business people and
really brainstorm a lot of things rather
than just being content creators
uh but outside of that i really enjoy
the direction that we've been going it's
like
it's it's really really really fun i do
have to thank you guys though because
after like we all like met up and had to
break the [ __ ] news like because you
guys all know this and we're playing for
camera that like you guys didn't know
but like you guys know and um when we
did have those meetings though i was
like talking to bart like dude
isn't it [ __ ] cool how like ride or
die or just team is in general because
even for you steve you you said like
you're like
um if you're here for the ups you got to
be here for the downs and i was like
dude there's so many people in the past
oh that's deep bro hey dude riders got
to ride riders got all right dude
because there's so many people in the
hills go up and down but you got to stay
on the bike dude
in the past they've they've taken
[ __ ] uh bonuses they've got the ups
and then when the downs came they turned
on us and [ __ ] ran or like whatever
and i was like dude like
this is not a two-way street for you
it's like
you're here when we're giving and giving
and giving and when [ __ ] hits the fan
it's like you bail and i was like dude
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i thought that
we were on the same page
dude i remember i remember i was on a
plane from costa rica i had kidney
stones and i was literally on a [ __ ]
little like puddle jumper
uh where i could see everything around
me and i was like dude if this engine
fails it's [ __ ] over we're just going
into the drink right and i remember
getting a text from bart and joe like
just like 15 minutes like
after takeoff and for some reason i got
i actually got the text because we're so
low to the ground and it was like hey
this sounds fake but 100 true and it's
like hey just so you know like we had a
bunch of excess funds for this year we
wanted to give everybody bonuses so yeah
you go it's just like one of those
things where i was like about to go home
and and try to figure out like oh man
okay so like i do have insurance but you
guys know how insurance is in america
it's like yes you have insurance but
also good news you have to pay like a
little bit of mortgage payment to do to
get your medical bills treated right
yeah so it's just nice to it was like
crazy like like to know that like i had
that little bit of a more of a buffer
that i didn't even expect at all coming
from these guys coming from the show
that i love doing already so i'm like
man i'm so lucky i have i have jk or
like i have other things i'm doing but
i'm so lucky that i also have these guys
like just to help that was like so great
for my morale like coming back even
though i was on [ __ ] pain and [ __ ]
but that's what i mean though is like i
have i have seen you guys give
generously like during the the ups and
so now yeah we you know sometimes i feel
like we gave too much bro
if that's true
it'd be nice to have some of that back i
know so now that we're getting our paint
drastically reduced
dramatically
oh the truth hurts i can only i can only
just go hey dude i that's not why i do
the show i'm not like who when's that
coming
it's never been like that
it will never be like that so it is what
it is and plus if we're gonna ride luna
to zero we're gonna ride jk to zero
[Music]
that was really awesome of you guys
because um after every meeting me and
joe would have to like debrief because
we just don't know how
how um it's gonna go and we also know
that like you know once you start
depending on income
um
like the like the from a realistic point
of view you live off of it right like
there's expenses and stuff like that so
as much as you want to do something for
fun
like even like your favorite [ __ ] toy
bike or car if it's like costing you
thousands of dollars if i got to sell it
even though this is like my favorite car
in the world
so like after every
like before every meeting me and joe are
nervous like [ __ ] how people are gonna
take this
and then after being like [ __ ] man
everyone's so [ __ ] cool to be like
dude it's not even about the money um we
just really want this is super fun and
we totally get it and we're gonna ride
with you guys i'm like oh man it's
[ __ ] awesome now let's have a
conversation about michael
yeah yeah mike
so we all get texts that are my scary
texts will be from corporate michael
never texts us this place has no
corporate
but there might as well be from
corporate it's like um
steven joe and bart bartholomew would
like to meet with you
[Laughter]
follow me bro and i got that text i'm
like oh my god i'm like okay so it's
over i'm like it's over yeah we're fired
yeah we're done
oh [ __ ] he's gonna fire he had like
punctuation and [ __ ] there was like
capital letters commas and periods
he [ __ ] actually presented like
information it was like crazy first of
all i was just talking to these
[ __ ] like literally eight
minutes ago in the group
[ __ ] so now it's like now it's
like hey um so is it cool to meet with
them at this particular time in this
particular place
what's the meaning about the meeting is
just about like you know how great
everything's going
how great everything is
it was like it was like oh we're going
to share some company updates and see
how you're doing exciting updates yeah
and then when they said exciting updates
when he said that in my head well when i
was reading the message i was like oh
i'm getting fired yeah yeah yeah i
didn't know you guys got the same text i
was like oh bart and joe can't say this
to my face yeah i'm like what i'm
literally just they just just facetime
me right now what that [ __ ] was so funny
michael is professional he's
professionals
our [ __ ] me mike like in our finance
meetings or whatever this fool got
[ __ ] pie graphs and [ __ ] so it's like
see how many [ __ ] ads we're getting
in the last six months now the pie is
like this
you [ __ ] know mike we're only doing
one battery every [ __ ] time just
wants it to
hurt
i love michael it's professional as [ __ ]
which is dope because it's the like
immediate like counter balance to me and
joe and i think is what we need you know
because remember yesterday julia was
like you know what i noticed um what i
learned that what jk doesn't do is they
have no sheets and we're like what do
you mean like there's more sheets every
company i go to and i'm like a lot of
paperwork
oh yeah michael's our sheets man if we
didn't have michael it would just be
like me and bar going
remember that thing yeah all right let's
go do that thing all right yeah cause we
saw our [ __ ] budget we're like holy
[ __ ] a thousand dollars on [ __ ]
vietnamese coffee i'm like how do you
know that he goes i ran out of the
banking statements and i saw all these
these coffee orders i was like oh [ __ ]
someone's doing actual business work
okay we don't need
where'd you get that [ __ ] number from
he's like he's actually like you know
like [ __ ] balancing what's going in
and out of our [ __ ] bank like normal
[ __ ] yeah regular business businesses do
yeah
never heard of it dude my the call that
i have with them was so [ __ ] funny
because these dudes go yo so we're going
to have to be reducing everybody's pay
you actually were already getting paid
lower than everyone so yours is the same
shut the [ __ ] up dude
they have no tax i love it
and they're like i don't know if you
knew that but but now you know
oh my god
corner cam baby let's go
honestly
me and joe are honest as [ __ ] dude well
why aren't you honest as [ __ ] that he
wasn't getting paid more before no
because he didn't earn it we have so in
our own timeline we have it where if
someone's been on for a year they get
the year bunk he hasn't got it yet i
just didn't know about any of those
things i didn't really even think about
it but it's funny that they were like
we're gonna be reducing but the good
news is years stays the same it's now
like more people are getting paid more
what you're being paid
i never got a yearbook you did you did
everyone does yeah yeah
oh you got your bum remember when jill
was [ __ ] pregnant or something
[ __ ] that's how we came up with it
yeah so when you stepped in
we gave you the
the full member pace started that's when
we that's where we came up with that
well i granted i never [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] because nikki always looked at
this [ __ ] so i didn't even know i was
like
okay he takes his paychecks and [ __ ]
track suits i say attach it to my body
yeah no on our end nikki is your
oh yeah
on our end like what we try to do is
like you know obviously it's not for the
money or whatever but then we always
like we we want to be able to reward
people that are down a ride with us we
also give silent bonuses and raises
without telling people yeah so for us
we kind of have our own like little
pastry
yeah we have our own little pay
structure on the back end but we just
don't really announce so we don't make
it
feel like it's like oh it's something
i'm trying to strive for right right you
know yeah oh [ __ ] this person's been
here for a year oh dude they're like
that much closer to being like like
regulars now you know so does the clock
start now
it's like go reset go it resets
that means a year from now it's going to
get lowered yeah it gets lower
like i said if we're still here a year
from now we're getting matching tattoos
and you're getting back the pay that you
used to have
let's go
hey one of the better one of the one of
the more fun internal bits that we had
leading up to this was that me and and
nick and anthony uh and uh and our boy
our boy uh ryan we're joking we're
joking about his name got me
i didn't want to say right anime um
we're joking about how we wanted to
unionize a jks for better pay more
health care all this [ __ ] and then and
then like that's the week after out of a
bit and then the week later it's like
hey dude we're union busting your asses
big time someone sold us out basically
we got a mole amongst the three of us
dude you know we used to give
so we try to sign up everybody for
health care no [ __ ] like three years ago
really oh no
uh five years ago yeah but
um basically the nature of the work
is it's not like a salary kind of thing
right with the 401k and all these things
so then
what we did was we're like well you know
what like health insurance is hell
expensive so like for full coverage it's
like what 400 300 bucks a month extra
we'll just give you that and then you
can go buy it and we added that into
everybody's pay
and then so after that we just stopped
telling people we just gave an extra 300
bucks
yeah so everyone knew that kind of stuck
around and they they were on the system
where they were just like on for that
classic case of the poor decisions of
your past are affecting the uh present
yeah the president the core members of
your president but you know we can look
past that you know it's a recession but
you i mean like
the the thing that sucks though i think
is like
sometimes you know it's like you learn
from your past relationship right and
then you learn like oh [ __ ] like i kind
of gave too much
but then maybe this new person you're
with deserves a lot of that because you
can appreciate them more and you're just
like i wish you know i gave all those
things to my new people yeah you're like
why did i give my diamond ring to the
[ __ ] last ex-girlfriend
this one's just the one that deserves it
yeah this one this one got the cracker
jack box ring yeah it's like this girl i
had to cut her paint
it's like this girl's even better
but i can't even give her the same [ __ ]
i gave the last one
this is like probably the most legit
video we've done in like a year honestly
we should have more business meetings on
camera
the michael set up and then the us calls
on camera because i all this i would
have said on camera dude these guys on
my call they were being so [ __ ] weird
in the jump i was like what the [ __ ] i
was like oh in my head the whole time
i'm like i'm for sure being fired how
are we coming up because you guys were
like so like how's everything with you
nick like how's your mental health yeah
like everything's belt's still brown and
we wanted to make sure we did we had
this call on a friday just in case they
were being all normal and [ __ ] and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this it's because
you're not used to our business side
because we never have to do that being
all normal and then i had to ask i was
like are you guys firing me or not
i had to ask i was like
am i the last one you're talking to
i need how did they all respond
i was surprised you guys didn't go ahead
and start talking as soon as you found
out no we have our own text where we
talk [ __ ] on you guys
yeah the union text right yeah with all
the extra jk members we're all we have
one text thread yeah i texted him right
away it was like you were being paid
more
the whole time and i was like i was like
what are you guys talking about i was
like i got another bump
i got a bump just for my awesome crypto
advice hey we're still here babies i
would have definitely [ __ ] with him if
i knew the order because if if i was
first i would have texted anthony when
like hey it was fun man thanks
that's funny like i would have [ __ ]
with him so he's like waiting to get the
call
so good damn it would have worked i
would have believed it
i can't believe we're still here let's
go
to the wheels following but i'll tell
you what till the [ __ ] wheels fall
we're running this [ __ ] to zero all the
way to zero i'm not leaving like we do
yeah
i love how our content is our company
you